- Super productive day so far as
were about to workout and
start this Biz Dev Sunday.
I just had Xander call me
the worst human on Earth--
- [Jordan] Because you work out?
- Nope, because I beat him
five-nothing in basketball.
(Jordan laughs)
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, I've been telling you.
Alright, Biz Dev
Sunday continues.
Last week was super successful.
Let's start with a recap.
VaynerSports exploded.
Tons of stuff
on VaynerSports.
Lot of stuff for our
athletes, I appreciate it.
Lot of good stuff for the
brands that reached out to us.
Got some good
sponsorship opportunities,
some great exposure
coming their way.
And so, that was super exciting.
The beanie stuff,
tons beanie stuff.
I've got to figure that out.
Almost too much beanie stuff.
We haven't even started that
and got a little bit of a list of
stuff for you guys this week.
This is gonna becoming a really
fun series, just a great way for
us to do business.
Got a small startup that wanted
to sponsorship thing but now
wants to give a piece of their
business so they're flying in
from middle America to see
AJ and I so just
some pretty cool stuff.
- Good hustle.
- Yeah, so far so good.
Alright first Biz Dev Sunday
this week is people with
seven-figure businesses selling
a physical product that isn't
a supplement or a
thing of that nature so if you
got a seven-figure business,
I'm looking for a direct
consumer biz development for
seven-figure businesses selling
actual product where I can build
and help build on the brand.
A lot of the biz
dev last week was,
"Hey, we got to $1 million
"selling our exercise ball or
"our belt or our iPhone case but
we don't think we can take it to
"that eight-figure level."
Lot of people offering equity,
made me think maybe there's
one company
that I should incubate.
Move you to New York, sit right
next my team and see if the
stuff that we do can
take it from $1 million to
$10 million in sales.
You guys know
me you follow me,
none of the
sleezy thing, you know.
I want it to be very clean,
direct to consumer product.
So, if you've got that and you
feel like you've tapped out with
you and your partner, that
you've hit a certain level and
you want to take
it to the next level,
both Wine Library
and VaynerMedia were
companies I've exploded.
I know how to do
that so hit me up on that.
Big one, I'm only
gonna pick one of these.
Don't waste your time or mine.
Okay, next Biz Dev
Sunday opportunity.
Hit me up if you get
an average of 1,500 likes
per post on your Instagram.
Hit it up, send us an email,
1,500+ Instagram in the title.
1,500+ Instagram
likes on average,
not one time, you got lucky.
That's your average, looking to
do some stuff to GaryVeeShop,
hit me up.
I'm just holding
them for show. (laughs)
Podcast.
Getting serious about
the GaryVee experience.
Number one, for
this Biz Dev Sunday
please subscribe (bell dings)
to my podcast.
Listen to it.
You know a lot of you
do this in the morning.
You know, you can listen to it.
A lot of you do
this in the morning.
You can listen to it.
Lot of you work, walk and work.
Podcast, check it.
Putting gout a lot
of of good stuff there.
The full Daymond John Fireside
Chat went on the podcast first.
I'm a big fan of
jab, jab, jab, right hook.
I'm able to duck
right hook, right hook,
right hook, right hook and so
I think the biggest way for me
to do things is when I feel
like there's value in return.
Still not out on
video so for example that.
Anyway, here's the
Biz Dev Sunday opportunity,
podcasts blowing up.
Podcast blowing up,
put it down there,
Tyler, 'cause I know
DRock you don't do these.
More utilitarian, you
got to do fancy episodes.
(bell dings)
Podcast blowup.
I'm looking for my
podcast to get more exposure.
If you've got a clean
way so many of you guys,
I don't like fucking
shortcuts, assholes.
Anyway, if you
write podcast reviews,
if you're a journalists, if you
got a way to biz dev my podcast,
I'm looking for more exposure,
I'm looking for more listeners,
not looking for any shortcuts.
No algorithms.
Clean, hard work, sweat
like I'm putting in here.
But exposure nonetheless.
Podcast blowup if you can use
some biz dev of my podcast
put it into the email this week.
Okay, breaking
news in this episode.
You were just saying,
we have to repeat it.
Go ahead. Fast.
- Alright, one of the best
pieces of advice I ever got from
Gary in social media comments
when people are commenting--
- And this is recent.
- This is very recent.
If you're putting out content
and people are commenting,
being assholes, whatever it is,
the mind stick shift was instead
of being mad, instead
of arguing with them,
instead of being a dick
back, feel bad for them.
Feel sorry that they're there
sitting at the computer typing
mean comments like while you're
there putting out good content.
That for me was one of
the biggest mind shifts.
- And you might not be
putting out good content.
You think it's good content
'cause it's your own content.
It might not be.
They may be right.
My whole point is I just feel
bad for somebody who's got so
much pain inside that they
need to tear other people down.
I just do, I just genuinely do
and especially it's easy for me
because I know how
this ends up. Right?
Like if they're right,
there's places to be cynical.
There's things to
be observant about.
I don't think like people
should blindly whatever
but if you've got that
much pain in you, you know?
- [Jordan] Yeah.
- For me, I always feel bad for
my commenters because they're
gonna lose historically.
We're filming Biz Dev Sunday.
We had a commercial
break from Jordan.
(Jordan laughs)
That's funny.
That's it.
So good Biz Dev Sunday.
Several things for
you guys to attack.
Tyler, do a little condensed
version of last week's
Biz Dev Sunday for
everybody who missed it.
End it right here with that.
But for everybody else
you can move on with your day.
We got a huge Monday coming up
so you'll get a bunch of good
content for the next DailyVee.
DRock, amazing job
on that Canada episode.
I thought that
was unbelievable fire.
One of my favorite episodes.
Casey's appearance probably
pushed your game up DRock.
Like the Million Dollar Man
says everybody's got a price.
Biz Dev Sundays, VaynerSports
if you are a startup brand,
biz dev small brands with
my up and coming athletes.
Stickers and posters.
I want to start
a beanie company.
I'm looking for somebody
who is really great at
sourcing high quality materials.
Clip it, in the
YouTube sections,
your favorite one minute clip.
We're gonna use the community to
decide which clips we should be
making in our
one minute Instagram,
Facebook and Twitter videos.
("Nocturnal" by JMKM)